since 2008 the marvel cinematic universe
has submitted its place as a pop culture
juggernaut but while some of those
movies are great
a few of them are just a good excuse to
get some more popcorn during your
40-hour movie marathon
here's every entry in the mcu from the
superheroes to skip
down to the best must-see movies of the
bunch thor
the dark world in theory 2013's the dark
world has everything you could want
except fun chris hemsworth is as
charming as ever
and it's based on one of the greatest
comic book runs of all time
it's got a star wars style attack on
asgard by spaceships flown by dark elves
the rock monsters from thor's very first
comics appearance
thor and loki teaming up for revenge
against the villain that killed their
mom
climaxing in a fist fight in which thor
and malakath are literally punching each
other so hard that they land in other
dimensions
unfortunately while all that sounds good
on paper it's actually both
super boring and confusing to boot
traits at chairs with
the incredible hulk when nick fury
showed up at the end of iron man and
hinted at the idea of a full-on shared
universe of superhero movies
fans were thrilled and then the
incredible hulk hit theaters a month
later and proved you should really be
careful
what you wish for it's not that the film
is terrible but it's something almost
worse
forgettable which is a real shame when
you consider that it does so much right
for one thing if you're going to make a
movie about a nerdy scientist with anger
issues so powerful they could level a
whole town
getting the guy who starred in fight
club to play bruce banner is a pretty
solid move
for another the filmmakers realized
audiences didn't need a full-blown
origin story to get up to speed tying
the hulk's origin into captain america
and the super soldier program was the
first stumbling step towards building
the full-on
shared universe in the end though it
just didn't quite land
iron man 2 sam rockwell literally
dancing across the stage to present his
army of iron man drones is
endlessly delightful but there's a lot
in this movie that doesn't involve
justin hammer busted a move
too and that's where it fails to measure
up to its predecessor
hammer and whiplash both serve as evil
versions of tony stark
bringing unnecessary complications to
the story even worse
the scene when stark goes down into his
basement with a particle accelerator to
somehow build a new element might be the
goofiest thing in the entire mcu
and those movies have a talking raccoon
from space
at the same time iron man 2 was a
confident stride towards the full mcu
introducing the black widow and war
machine and even teasing thor's arrival
in the next film
there's a lot there to like and even if
it's outweighed by the bad stuff
we'll always have justin hammer's dance
moves
thor iron man 2 might have been the
first big step towards fleshing out the
marvel universe
but thor was the first time we actually
got to see its scope in action
with thor we got asgard in all its glory
complete with a rainbow laser bridge
epic battles against frost giants and
perhaps most importantly
those big old jack kirby hats that norse
gods apparently love to wear
it even gave us a viking god robot with
a face made of death lasers
and it introduced us to arguably the
best villain in the whole
mcu loki like thor the dark world though
the original thor film somehow ended up
feeling like less than the sum of its
parts
it should have been great but it ended
up merely okay
iron man 3. iron man 3 tried to do
something different
and it succeeded brilliantly
unfortunately what it was trying to do
was defy
expectations by completely undermining
everything fans loved about iron man in
the mcu
iron man 3 explores how the smartest guy
in the room deals with living in a world
that's becoming something he can't
predict
it's a movie about a superhero with an
anxiety disorder
which results in iron man spending the
entire movie not wanting to be iron man
and thus being iron man as little as
possible plus there was the whole fake
mandarin thing
which some people loved but most fans
were either confused or disappointed by
director shane black deserves credit for
his bold vision which made for a good
movie
just not a good marvel movie doctor
strange
when 2016's doctor strange was announced
the big question for comics fans was how
the mind-bending psychedelic sorcerer of
the mystical marvel universe was going
to fit into the mcu
as comic book fans know things get
pretty weird
and from a visual standpoint the
filmmakers absolutely nailed it the
splitting realities in the movie's fight
scenes were beautifully weird
and the ghostly ethereal plane were life
and death battles for the fate of the
earth could rage unseen was great for
showing how different stephen strange's
world was
from a story standpoint though it seemed
a little too familiar as the story beats
were basically iron man with magic
still you can do worse than copying one
of the most popular superhero films ever
and the fantastic climax with strange's
time-bending bargain with dormammu
is one of the best finales in the mcu to
date
avengers age of ultron juggling a
massive cast of superheroes is a
difficult task
and while avengers age of ultron doesn't
manage it quite as well as the other two
avengers films
or captain america civil war it does a
pretty good job of balancing character
bits with all-out
action sure some parts seem half-baked
like tony stark apparently forgetting
every lesson he learned in iron man 3
and thor's weird spirit quest
but it boasts a great final battle
that's the best you can do
not to mention the introduction of fan
favorite characters vision and scarlet
witch
avengers age of ultron isn't perfect but
it still packs in a lot of fun
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. the first
guardians of the galaxy movie proved
that the mcu could get weird and cosmic
and still be incredibly entertaining
the second one proved that wasn't a
fluke if anything it went even bigger
the first movie brought us stuff like
the novacore and ronin the accuser
but volume 2 has about a half hour of
superheroes battling ego the living
planet
it's got waves of space drones swarming
into starship battles
a warp drive sequence that knows exactly
how silly it is
and it features the best stan lee cameo
in cinema history
and the single best use of a zune in
anything ever
ant-man it's tempting to say ant-man
shouldn't have worked as well as it did
and that a second-tier superhero with
the ability to get really tiny and talk
to ants
was a big surprise when he started to
rake in billions
really though it's not that unexpected
after all
marvel's first big movie success came
from a pretty obscure
d-lister from the pages of tomb of
dracula
audiences have always been interested in
stories that twist the expected
superhero plot points around into
something new
and that's where ant-man really delivers
as easy as it would have been to portray
scott lang as a microscopic version of
iron man
his story felt different hey we the guys
yeah we're the good guys man yeah we're
the good guys
it feels kind of kind of weird you know
the movie has its missteps
like going out of its way to justify not
having the wasp show up until the sequel
but on the other hand this is a movie in
which the hero loses a
fight with a toy train and chekhov's gun
is
actually chekhov's 60 ton tank
the avengers that the avengers works at
all is pretty impressive
but that it works as well as it did
that's basically a miracle
even less than a decade later it's
difficult to remember that this was the
first time that anything like this had
been attempted
a movie that combined characters who had
been established in their own films
each with their own tone and style in
bringing them together
joss whedon had to balance the fantasy
of thor
the snarky sci-fi of iron man and the
sincere superheroics of captain america
combining them all along with hulk
hawkeye and black widow
with stakes that were high enough to
bring everyone together for a single
adventure
and this movie doesn't those big stakes
mostly result from an army of faceless
aliens
but even that paid off years later in
avengers infinity war
and loki getting hulk smashed like a
looney tunes character was the most fun
superhero movies had ever been
puny god
iron man it's safe to say iron man
surprised us all
it's not that we expected it to be bad
tony stark's origin story is a pretty
good fit for a hollywood action movie
it had a great cast and while director
jon favreau might have been best known
for elf
that wasn't really a bad thing but still
none of us expected
it to be so good that it would become
the foundation of the entire mcu
to say that it was an exceptionally
powerful launch would be an
understatement
there are times when this feels less
like a superhero movie and more like a
popcorn revenge flick where the hero
just happens to have a flying suit of
armor
but it did its job so well that those
shortcomings are easy to forgive
captain america the first avenger the
first avenger does origin stories better
than most
and a lot of that has to do with chris
evans in a franchise that's full of
amazing casting choices
evans pulls off the incredible feat of
embodying a square jawed
relentlessly earnest product of the
military industrial complex
in a way that makes him impossible not
to like for all the super strength
that's a character whose real super
power is making you believe in him
and that's exactly what this movie does
i'm gonna do this all day
as good as it was on its own it also
serves as the proof of concept for the
superhero movie as a period piece
and gave the mcu a history that went
further back than 2008 in tony stark's
cave
guardians of the galaxy the first
guardians of the galaxy movie manages to
balance so much stuff going on that you
almost don't notice how complicated it
is for all the fun you're having
it's got a team of lovable misfits
dealing with their own issues
while fighting against a massive threat
expansive interstellar empires
and a retro feel supported by a classic
rock soundtrack that doesn't feel like
it's wallowing in the past
all that and still tells a story so fun
it made rocket raccoon a household name
it breaks the formula in every way it
can to the point where it's a superhero
team movie that ends with a dance-off
and the heroes literally saving the
universe with the power of friendship
captain america the winter soldier
everything about the winter soldier
reinforces the idea that captain america
is exactly the guy you want to have the
power to save the world
the notebook full of pop culture
references that he needs to look up to
understand the world around him
the friendship with sam wilson that
starts with bonding over their wartime
experience
the loyalty to his friends that leads
him to risk his own life to save bucky
he even gives his opponents one last
chance to back out before he
beats up an elevator full of traitors
all of these pieces did
add up to a hole that's incredible even
before you get to know how much of the
movie is based around steve rogers just
kicking the living hell out of bad guys
that stuff's pretty fun too captain
america civil war
even though steve rogers and bucky
barnes are unquestionably the focus of
civil war
there's a pretty convincing argument to
be made that this movie should have been
called
avengers civil war instead it has
everyone in it
and they aren't just cameos either
ant-man hawkeye
scarlet witch and war machine all get
huge character developing moments in the
middle of a superheroic royal rumble
while the avengers are split by a
villain who wound up getting exactly
what he wanted
and if that wasn't enough it's also the
movie that introduced movie audiences to
black panther and spider-man
the characters are never flattened out
to fit and the three-way
fight at the end has not only some of
the best action in the mcu
but some of the most emotional moments
too
black panther after his debut in civil
war
t'challa's first solo movie came with
some pretty high expectations
not only did it live up to them it blew
right past them for one of the mcu's
best movies
maybe it's because chadwick boseman's
t'challa is a character struggling with
the weight of expectations himself
the black panther is more than up for
the challenge but the journey he takes
to get there is full of compelling
complications
from the reveal that his father wasn't
the flawlessly honorable man that he
thought
to an enemy with some very justifiable
anger at the world around him
it's a superhero struggle that goes far
beyond the punch-out battle in the
climax
black panther never shies away from its
high-tech comic book roots
but tells a story that's very much
rooted in the real world
and it does it beautifully avengers
infinity war
more than any other superhero movie
infinity war captures the feeling of an
epic comic book crossover there are
multiple
interconnected stories going on at the
same time each with its own flavor
bridging different story arcs and making
sure every single character gets a
moment in the spotlight
when it comes together at the end it's a
fight across multiple planets where the
unbelievably high stakes become very
real for both the characters
and the fans who have been invested in
these movies for a full 10 years
that's a tough enough bit of
storytelling to pull off well even in
comic books
and they've had decades of practice
seeing it done here
in a single movie that still has that
feeling of encompassing a whole universe
no other movie has ever done that and
it's hard to imagine another one doing
it this well
thor ragnarok to say that ragnarok lives
heavily from walt simonsen's mid-80s
epic run on the mighty thor
is putting it mildly the only things in
this movie that weren't directly
inspired by simonsen
are the pieces it pulls directly from
marvel's more recent planet hulk
storyline
right down to the hulk's gladiator gear
the thing is
taika with tt's film chops up all those
pieces
and rearranges them into something
that's both different and genuinely
hilarious
that's exactly what doug used to say see
you later new doug
that part isn't surprising considering
that before ragnarok
huatiti was probably best known for
co-directing the vampire mockumentary
what we do in the shadows but it takes
advantage of chris hemsworth's
infuriatingly good comedic timing
ow sorry to be sure spider-man
homecoming
as good as it is on its own the fact
that peter parker swings into action
after
15 other movies means we don't have to
waste time with an origin story
thematically homecoming builds on
everything that came before in a truly
incredible way
with direct callbacks to tony stark's
character arc that show how different
peter parker is
from the hero he's trying to impress the
idea of a superhero
universe erupting around otherwise
normal people
is the conflict that drives everything
about the movie take that away
and you've still got great characters
great action and one of the best scenes
in the franchise
with it though you've got pure magic
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too